PROFESSOR: Here is
where the power of this
comes when you
decide that you're
going to invent all possible
Hamiltonians at this moment.
You've reduced the infinite
dimensional space of functions
in the line to
two points, so you
have a two-dimensional vector
space, dramatic reduction.
So here we decide, OK,
here is the Hamiltonian.
And it's going to be
a two-by-two matrix,
and it better be Hermitian.
So what options do I have?
Well, Hermitian means transpose
complex conjugated gives you
back the same matrix.
So let's try to
parametrize such a matrix.
I could put a0, a real quantity
here, and another real quantity
in the bottom size.
And if they are real, the
transpose complex conjugate
will remain the same.
That's OK.
So I could put a0 and a1 here.
I'll do it in a
little different way.
I'll put a0 plus a3,
and a0 minus a3 here.
Now, the thing is that a0
and a3 have to be real.
So I'll use a0, a1, a2, and a3.
And they all should be real.
So here, transpose
complex conjugate
doesn't affect these things.
They are the same.
That's good.
Here, we can a1 minus ia2.
This is a complex number.
And the only thing
that must happen
is that, when I transpose
a complex conjugate,
I must get the same thing.
So I should put
here a1 plus ia2.
Because if I transpose this,
I will have it on this side.
And then I complex conjugate
it, and it becomes this term.
Similarly, if I transpose
this term, it goes here.
But then complex
conjugated, it becomes that.
So actually, I claim the most
general two-by-two Hermitian
matrix.
Time independent-- you see,
all our quantum mechanics
this semester has been time
independent potentials.
So here it's time independent.
And now, this is the
most general Hamiltonian
you could have.
That's it.
So when you see
something like that,
you realize that in an hour
or two or after some thinking,
you will have solved the
most general dynamical system
with two degrees of freedom
in quantum mechanics.
So I will write this as
a0 times this matrix,
plus a1 times this matrix,
plus a2 times this matrix,
plus a3 times this matrix.
That's exactly what
you have in there.
Multiply in these constants
and add these matrices,
and they give you
all what we have.
So actually, these are the basic
Hermitian two-by-two matrices.
And if you multiply
them by real numbers,
you still are Hermitian.
And if you add them,
So the most general Hermitian
matrix has four parameters.
And it is a space of matrices
spanned by these four matrices.
They are so famous,
these matrices,
that this is called sigma
1, this is called sigma 2,
and this is called sigma 3.
And they're called
the Pauli matrices.
Well, but let's put
units to these things.
We want to write Hamiltonians.
So let's make sure we have
units that do the job.
The Hamiltonian must
have units of energy.
So we could do a Hamiltonian
that has units of energy.
So I'll write h omega, which has
units of energy, omega 1, sigma
1, plus h--
I'll put it even over 2--
h omega 2, over 2, sigma 2,
plus h omega 3, over 2, sigma 3.
Now you would say,
well, why didn't you
use the first matrix.
I could have used
the first matrix,
but the first matrix is
proportional to the identity.
We already learned in
our course that if you
have an extra constant
operator in the Hamiltonian,
it doesn't change your
calculations in any way.
You had the Hamiltonian for
the harmonic oscillator.
It was h omega N plus 1/2.
And the 1/2 was an
additive constant
that never played
any important role.
So this would be an additive
constant to the energy.
It would tell you
how you're measuring
the energy from what level.
So it's not very interesting.
You can use it sometimes,
but it's definitely not
all that interesting.
So I'll do a little
variation of this
by writing omega 1, h over
2, sigma 1, plus omega 2,
h over 2, sigma 2, plus
omega 3, h over 2, sigma 3.
And then you say, look,
that's interesting, OK,
I have an omega on this thing.
But omega is fine.
We know what it is.
It's a frequency,
1 over time unit.
But this has units
of angular momentum.
h bar has units of
angular momentum.
And the thing that is a
little mysterious here
is that we seem to
have three of them.
So maybe somehow this has
to do with angular momentum.
So let's investigate
it a little bit.
Well, they have units
of angular momentum.
So maybe I can call some first
component of angular momentum,
h bar over 2 sigma 1, second
h 1 over 2 sigma 2, and the
third component of angular
momentum, h bar over 2 sigma 3.
Well, those are just names.
But we can try to do a
computation with them.
We can try to see what is
the commutator of Sx with Sy.
And happily, these are matrices,
so it's a natural thing
to do commutators.
So you would have h
bar over 2, sigma 1,
with h bar over 2,
sigma 2, commutator.
And it's equal to h bar
over 2 times h bar over 2,
sigma 1, sigma 2,
minus sigma 2, sigma 1.
So it's h bar over 2
times h bar over 2.
And let's do this.
Sigma 1 is 0, 1, 1, 0.
Sigma 2 is 0, minus i, i, 0,
minus 0, minus i, i, 0, 0, 1,
1, 0.
OK, I have to do
all that arithmetic.
Happily, this is not that bad.
Let's see if I
don't make mistakes.
OK, here I get two terms,
an i from the first,
a 0 here, a 0, and
a minus i here--
minus-- and minus i,
a 0, a 0, and an i,
which is h bar over 2,
times h bar over 2, times--
oh, they don't cancel.
They seem to cancel,
but there's some minus--
it's actually twice--
of those, so 2i minus 2i, 0, 0.
And here we get a 2 cancels
this and then i goes out.
So I'll have with
this factor and i out
is i h bar times h bar over
2, times the matrix 1 minus 1,
0, 0.
Somehow, it gave that.
h bar over 2, 1 minus 1--
1 minus 1 is sigma 3.
And h bar over 2 sigma 3
is Sz, so this is all Sz.
So it's i h bar Sz.
So this stuff, Sx, Sy,
is giving you i h bar Sz.
And that was exactly
like angular momentum.
So not only it has the
units of angular momentum,
it has the commutation
relations of angular momentum.
Hermitian operators,
two-by-two matrices,
they used to be r cross
p, all these derivatives,
complicated stuff.
Here it is-- with
two-by-two matrices,
you've constructed
angular momentum.
What we've constructed at
this moment is spin 1/2.
A whole spin 1/2 system is
nothing else than that--
angular momentum and the freedom
of having two discrete degrees
of freedom.
The interpretation that
what they have to do
is spin up and spin
down is something
that physicists came up with.
But the mathematics was there
waiting as the simplest quantum
mechanical problem.
Considering [? who wrote ?]
the Schrodinger equation,
maybe, if he had been more
mathematically inclined,
he could have discovered,
five minutes later, spin.
But he wanted to figure out the
wave function of the hydrogen
atom and scattering and all
these very complicated things.
So needless to say, the other
commutation relations work out.
So if you check that Sy with
Sz, you will get i h bar Sx.
And if you do finally Sz with
Sx, you will get i h bar Sy.
So these two-by-two matrices
satisfy this property.
And there is a little
more to be said.
I want to say a few
more things about it
because it's counter-intuitive
and therefore very nice.
Half of the semester in
805 is devoted to spin 1/2.
It takes a while
to understand it.
So I wanted you to
see it, at least once.
And the problem is the
physical interpretation
takes time to get accustomed.
So on the other hand, we
did write the Hamiltonian.
So the Hamiltonian was
omega 1 Sx, plus omega 2 Sy,
plus omega 3 Sz.
And it's there--
S1, S2, S3, second line.
And this is the Hamiltonian.
So people write it sometimes as
omega dotted with an S vector,
as it's saying it has
three components, as omega
has three components as well.
And there's a lot of
physics in this Hamiltonian.
It's the simplest Hamiltonian,
but it actually represents
a spin in a magnetic field.
And what it will make
it do, this Hamiltonian,
if we solve the differential,
this two-by-two matrix
equation, we will find that
the spin starts to precess.
That's the origin of
nuclear magnetic resonance,
spinning, precessing spins, that
the machine makes them precess.
And they send a
signal and you detect
the density of different
fluids in the body.